はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ//
あぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁん♡
プルプルプルプルプル
髪の毛ぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！
もう一回黒くしたよぉ！
こんちゃー
はじめしゃちょーでぇぇぇぇすｗｗｗｗｗｗ
僕は気付いてしまいましたぁぁぁぁぁ
幽霊と一緒にいるためにはぁぁぁ、元気があればいいんですよぉぉぉ、元気があればぁぁぁぁ！
幽霊も元気になる(意味深ｗｗｗ　　いやそれじゃダメだ
それじゃだめだけどぉぉ！結局は心の問題ですよぉぉぉ。
霊が居ようと霊が居なくても
私は気づいてしまった
ここ(心)が強ければ何も関係なぁぁぁぁい‼
というわけでね僕はね
この部屋の幽霊をぶっ飛ばすためには
ぶっ飛ばす必要はないですぶっ飛ばしても
帰っくるかもしれないから
除霊はしない方がいいらしいだから
除霊もしないし
幽霊さーん
聞いてますー？
居てもいいよ！　いてもいいけど
仲良くしよー
霊感の強い友達ここに来て
その人いわく幽霊がいるらしいです
幽霊はいるらしいですけども
決して悪い霊ではないってことを言ってました
なのでひょっとしたら所沢の霊かもしれないし
おばけの霊かもしれないけど
まあ去年あたりからずっとなんかそういう感じあったんですけども
特に悪いこともないし
むしろ比較的に去年は安全に過ごせたと思っているんで
まあ別に幽霊の一人や二人いても
いいのかなと思っております
だからぁね
嫌なことがあったりね不吉なことがあったりっしたら
結局自分の心の持ちようなんすよ
ソウ
要するに世の中はな
自分のソウル、魂があれば
なんでもできる…
こともないと思います
今日はこの辺のお化けも楽しませるために
ハイ！！
絶叫！ふうせん芸人
コレすごくないすか!?
なんかぁ
なんか風船が付いているんですけども
服に入れるとどんどん膨らんでって
爆発するらしいです
ふぉぉ⁽テンション上がってきた⁾
というわけでね！今日はもうね
芸術です
今日はもう爆発するしかない!（決心）
この俺が　俺自身が‼
もう‼爆発しかないんすよ
爆発する事によって
幽霊も心が引き締まり
ほっとになるかもしれない!（俺いいこと言った）
そうでしょう?だから
今日は幽霊も俺も君たちも‼
みんなで一緒に
爆発して最高気分になろうじゃないの‼
（パタ‼ボギ‼パタパタっ!
はっはっはっ（息が荒くて穴が痛いおーー）
痛痛‼
パタパタッ!
はっはぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
おれ気付いたよ
世の中はな
結局勢いなんですよ
結局世の中は勢いがありゃいいんすよ（キラっ）
（ブーーーーーーー）（観覧注意）
あぁ～
（ぴょん）
【はじめ遊んでいます】
いや、そうゆうゲームじゃないでしょ
なんか飛ぶんですけど
（ビューーーー）（風船膨らんでます）
やべ！
（バン‼）
はじめ観覧注意